unless you've been incarcerated and
caged up you have no concept of freedom
you take it for granted when I first got
out of prison I was scared you know it
was a whole new world for me and I
needed a place you know that I could
call home where I can kind of decompress
and feel relaxed and now I'm home and
it's like wow you know this is what
people are talking about I grew up in
Southern California everything was good
in school until my father passed away
and then things got kind of rough for me
I decided to start hanging out with the
wrong crowd and ended up committing a
lot of crimes and then finally got
sentenced to two life terms for
attempted murder and drive-by shooting I
was 17 years old when I committed my
crime I'm 36 now I just paroled about
five and a half months ago then I'm a
participant in the homecoming project
the homecoming project is a transitional
housing program where we're combined
with a host in the community who houses
us for a stipend for six months and kind
of be reintegrated into the community
by somebody from the community what's
unique about it is that I get to live in
an independent living arrangement where
I get to do my own laundry the my own
cooking - my own cleaning my host
Kenny's horn and she's been involved in
the community for like 35 years or
something like that here in Oakland and
because of that she has a certain
reputation and people respect her for
that
a lot of the churches and community
organizations that we distribute food to
or with and they're really embracing and
welcoming because Kandy's the one who
brought me to them it wasn't just me
showing up at their doorstep my
connection with Jesse was almost
immediate after speaking with him over
the phone we were able to just ask each
other questions and kind of see how we
felt about certain things
as a host I wanted to be able to provide
housing where they will feel comfortable
and feel free I'm really thankful that I
had the opportunity for him to be in my
circle to be a part of what it is that I
do because he has really shown his self
that hey I really want to I really want
to do my best I really want to give back
it makes me feel great because I'm
helping someone and that's what my heart
desire is
[Music]
so the homecoming project pays my rent
for the first six months my six month
will be up next month after that I have
the option of either finding my own
place somewhere else or making my own
rental arrangement with candy my host
right now for me this is home and she's
expressed you know that I can stay here
forever if I want to and I don't see
myself moving anywhere I came to the Bay
Area not knowing where I was gonna live
you know coming out of prison but
Kenny's been like a mother to me the
moment I met her she told me welcome
home this is your home anything that I
can do for you any way that I can help
I'm here for you and I just thank God
for being here today a free man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]